russia's military says it's used
hypersonic missiles against ukraine
this has not been confirmed but if true
it would be the first time they've been
utilized since this war began
the armed forces of the russian
federation continued their special
operation
on march 18 the dagger aviation missile
system destroyed a large underground
warehouse storing ammunition of
ukrainian troops in ivano france's
region
let's get more now from imran khan he
joins us live from the capital first of
all imran what are you hearing about the
use of hypersonic missiles
well what we're hearing is that the
russians are saying that they have used
them uh what they say is according to
the interfax news agency uh that it used
them on saturday to destroy a large
underground depot
for missiles and aircraft ammunition
that was in ukraine's ivano francovix
region uh now the interfax news agency
also goes on to say that it also
destroyed ukrainian military radio and
reconnaissance uh centers near the
postal
near the port city of odessa as well
using coastal missiles so something
coming from russian navy perhaps
such is the nature of warsami that often
new weapon systems are news now i've
been reading several blogs military
blogs over the last few days they've
been taking a close look at the types of
weapons
being used now although this is the
first time the russians are publicly
saying that they've used hypersonic
missiles it may well
not be the first time they've actually
used them now in the past few days in
the key we've seen cruise missiles shot
from russian territory they've been
intercepted by ukrainian air defense
systems as well we're also hearing about
the fact that the russians are
introducing kamikaze drones uh into the
conflict as well again that's according
to the military blogs that uh we're
taking a look at uh oftentimes those are
ex-military people uh who are taking a
close look at that so a lot of new
weapon system which is the case in war
are being used here but
like you say this is the first time that
we are hearing a confirmation about
hypersonic missiles
we're also uh we've got that call there
from the president for talks but talks
have been ongoing haven't they is there
concern some worry that maybe they're
about to stall that's right
well the talks like you say have been
ongoing this is the fourth round of
talks it went on uh all day uh yesterday
we don't know if they're going to be
talking again we normally found out find
out around about one o'clock uh local
time uh whether the talks are ongoing
they're doing this by video link now
there was some optimism just a few days
ago when uh one of somebody one of the
ukrainians who's very close to the talks
leading the talks uh suggested that
they've gone into subcommittees which
meant that they were bashing out the
nitty-gritty however
that seems to be uh less uh of a concern
now because the talks seem to have a
disconnect the russians are asking for
very big pictures stuff the ukrainians
are asking for the russians to leave
ukrainian territory for humanitarian aid
to be taken to places that are desperate
for it and also uh that the russians
actually stop occupying uh crimea and
other parts of reason they've been in
crimea for about eight years now so
there's a there's a disconnect there but
every single time uh president vladimir
zelensky of ukraine makes a statement
people are really looking closely at
that statement picking it apart to try
and figure out what he means let's take
a look now at what he had to say his
latest statement
this is the time to meet this is the
time to speak time to restore
territorial integrity and fairness for
ukraine otherwise the losses of russia
will be such that you won't have any
resources to get up after that
today in russia they celebrate the
annexation of crimea i would like to
highlight one detail they reported that
overall there were two hundred thousand
people participating hundred thousand
outside and approximately ninety five
thousand in the stadium this is the
exact number of the russian manpower
involved in the invasion of ukraine
fourteen thousand dead bodies and
hundreds of thousands of wounded this is
the exact number of russian forces
during this war
this is the price in just over three
weeks
well clearly very angry words there from
president vladimir zelinsky particularly
directed at the russians for celebrating
uh in effect the invasion of ukraine
once again he's also reiterating the
fact that the ukrainian demands are very
clear very simple russia gets out of
ukraine before any serious negotiations
on the future of ukraine can take place
also once again you didn't hear it there
but once again he's also asking the west
for uh more weapons particularly air
defense systems fighter jets uh one of
the one of the key claims here now is
close the skies that's a appeal to nato
for a no-fly zone that's not happening
nato have
constantly said that they won't do that
for fear of escalation now uh the cl the
the claim seems to be changing uh what
the ukrainians want is their own fighter
jets to be able to close the skies
themselves when that happens or not
remains to be seen but clearly the
ukrainian position hardening when it
comes to uh defending themselves
all right thanks so much imran khan